[Music]
hello everyone welcome to ops 210
program you're talking about
infrastructures code and how you can do
it at scale as an enterprise I I'm
Morgan type L I'm one of our strategic
cloud engineers working with our largest
enterprise customers on all of our
DevOps best practices and how you can
really effectively use infrastructure as
code
I'm Andrew here Oh there's actually two
clickers here which is nice thanks
Morgan - I'm Andrew Phillips I'm a
product manager in GCP working on
continuous delivery long story short
I've suffered on all sides of the
software delivery space I've also been a
head of duct tape so hopefully had an
infrastructure officially so hopefully
have some good familiarity with what the
challenge is here just a quick reminder
we can there's mics here so we will
obviously be taking questions live as
well but if you do have a question at
any point during the presentation you
can put it in the dory using your app
and then we will try to answer them from
the floor and also from the QA and will
obviously get round to any that we
aren't able to answer here
okay so let's you know let's set the
stage here what's the actual problem
that we're trying to address well
typically what we see quite frequently
is when users or companies or teams get
started with the cloud you know oh yes I
have access to a cloud project that's
great and let's you know follow a couple
of tutorials or let's try a bunch of
things out and then you know I copy
paste some commands and then I click
around a little bit to set up some
configuration and eventually I have you
know my POC environment running or I've
tried a few things out and I got a bunch
of things that I've created maybe some
networking config maybe a couple of
clusters here and there maybe some V PC
stuff and a buck couple of buckets and
so on and so forth and I mean there's
there's a whole bunch here some iam
permissions but it's kind of manageable
and you know maybe some of its not
necessary but if I have a few things
lying around that's not terrible and
actually GCP does a nice job of warning
you about things that haven't been used
and so on and so forth but let's imagine
you decide that you really like this you
know this cloud
stuff is great and you feel it's gonna
help your company a lot and then you get
all your development teams or your
friends to work on it and then you know
you add more resources suddenly you've
got a whole bunch of projects so maybe
you want to start doing some stuff I
don't all I mean org as in the GCP
construct so you don't have to set up
the same permissions or the same
policies these kind of things all over
the place so you've now got two places
where your configures already living and
then I think you kind of know where this
is going dot dot dot and suddenly you're
all in on the cloud you got tons and
tons of projects you've got orga level
config that's quite complicated and you
have all these 500 projects each one of
which is set up well similarly but then
slightly differently and some of them
are maybe in compliance and some of them
out of compliance and really config
sprawl I think we most of us have heard
this term we don't want to go there if
we have been there already we want to
get out of it and if we haven't been
there yet good for you but we're going
to talk about how we can try to prevent
this what's the answer at least what
we're going to be talking about today is
how we can manage this complexity with
relatively well known patterns
thankfully so there's nothing too crazy
here using infrastructure as code and
automation to handle both the definition
and the safe rollout of configuration to
all the various places that we need to
have in GCP and we're going to look at a
couple of tools to do this a code repo
we're going to look at cloud build and
we're going to look at deployment
templates here to reflect the
configuration that we want to have so
what are some of the benefits of using
infrastructures code well similar
benefits to using any type of configures
code you've got all the nice bits about
using code management things are
versioned you have you know things like
stable IDs through commits so you can
always point back at the previous
version you can have multiple people
working on the same things etc etc you
have this idea that rather than
infrastructure being in whatever state
it happens to be in you actually have a
place that specifies what you want the
end
structure to look like and you know
that's useful for things like drift
detection or just as an audit trail but
of course is relevant also for things
like disaster recovery scenarios if you
want to bring back something to the stay
that it was and so on it's nice and
declarative so rather than hiding the
intended state in a bunch of g-cloud
commands or in a bunch of imperative
commands you can actually look at it and
it's hopefully human readable and it
gives you a sense of what it is that you
were going to set up I talked about
auditable a little bit and then of
course it's modular if you have the
right type of configures code or
infrastructure as code tooling or
language that you're using you don't
just have to have one enormous flat file
that is copied or duplicated all over
the place some parts of it you have the
ability to do things like inherit
sections so that you can have you know a
shared definition for maybe some
networking config that you use in a
whole bunch of different places so we
talked about code we talked about some
of the benefits of managing this
configuration as code and what we've
learned when we talk about source code
over the years is that you know there
are certain practices that are really
useful in order to make sure that we
don't break stuff when we build
applications and if we're gonna think
through what's the ICD or what
deployment might look like for
infrastructure is code we can use
exactly the same processes by analogy to
think through what that might mean so
most of us have probably heard of
continuous integration for application
code you know the idea that whenever I
submit or propose a change to my source
code I should run a whole bunch of tests
and verifications to make sure that this
change actually is going to be good and
not just eyeball it and think like Oh
looks fine let's try it out and of
course we can do something similar for
infrastructure as code I'm proposing a
change to my infrastructure definitions
maybe a change to a firewall configure
or something like that an automation can
give me a lot of information about
whether that change is safe whether that
change is good at the very simplest
level automation can tell me whether I
actually have made a syntax error and
the new configures code is broken or is
not broken and so we'll talk a little
bit about how we can you know what kinds
of information we can feed back
to whoever is working with the
infrastructures code in order to make
sure that we have good confidence that
the code change we're proposing actually
works and then if we again we follow
that analogy a step further yes
you know we assured ourselves that a
code change or a config change that
we're going to make is safe but now
instead of just saying great we'll just
apply it everywhere and see what happens
what we've learned with application
releases is that it makes sense to have
a gradual progression some process where
you know we maybe run some integration
tests or we have a staging environment
or we maybe even do advanced things like
a Bluegreen deployment there's lots of
practices that we've discovered that
make the rollout of a new config or a
new application change safer and of
course we can do the same thing for
infrastructures code as well we can
think through how we can safely roll out
these config changes progressively to
the places where they need to go as
opposed to saying oh I've approved the
change now somebody gets their laptop
clones the repo and goes apply or does
that in cloud shell or somewhere else
and as I hinted that when I talked about
the progressive rollout one of the
dimensions that come into this is that
of course we have multiple environments
in most cases you don't just have one
set of config for one GCP project or one
environment it's very common that you
know as we think about our
infrastructure landscape we have this
notion of logical differences we have
the dev environment or the test
environment or the staging environment
for our teams or our applications and we
also have inevitably differences across
those environments and so what we want
to do is a we want to be able to reflect
that difference in our infrastructure as
code so we can easily see what the state
of our dev and tests and staging
environments should be and we also want
to have a rollout process that takes
these changes through the various
environments so that we don't I mean we
can if we want to but it's often safer
rather than applying the changes to
everything at once let's take an example
case if you're going to change a
firewall rule it's kind of useful to
change it in the staging environment
first to see if your application still
works
before you decide to apply that same
kind of change to your production
environment where if you get it wrong
you might be breaking your users who
suddenly can't access the application
anymore so there's a longer or just
pause of this there's a longer
discussion about how environments map to
different GCP projects and I think the
short answer is that there is no right
answer but we're very happy to talk
about different patterns there suffice
it to say that from the perspective of
what we're going to talk about today it
doesn't really matter your dev and test
and staging environments could all be
resources in the same project or they
could be spread across multiple projects
so now having taken these principles
about CI and CD let's now look at how we
can actually technically use tools that
are available to implement this kind of
flow so what we're gonna have we're
gonna have a code repo that has
infrastructure as code definitions for
multiple environments we're going to
submit or propose a change to this
definition or rather Morganton will
because I just do the hand wavy slide
but we're going to have CI an automation
process providing feedback on that pull
request to tell us about whether it's a
good pull request or not and we'll talk
about some tooling we can use as part of
that process to give us more useful
information then we're going to have a
review process the nice thing about
using a code repo is that we kind of get
that for free through the pull request
model and there's actually some nice you
know if you depending on which
repository service you're using whether
it's github or github or bitbucket or
whatever just a github github you have
nice options about adding access control
and you can require that certain people
are the only people who can do reviews
and so on somebody's going to review
this code change after we've got the
feedback for things like policy
compliance then we're going to decide
maybe or maybe not it's good to go and
then of course once it's done we are
going to take this config change and
we're actually going to apply it
progressively to the various
environments that it has to go to so
what are some of the design principles
if you like in terms of the automation
that we're going to be looking at here
we're going to be using some release
pipelines
to do the automation so that
going to be you know not going to be
somebody following a wiki page that's
actually going to be fully automated and
again we're going to see that we can
store this automation in the repo as
well as configures code we're going to
have a sort of equivalent to integration
testing or to testing obviously for
application code we understand what
infra integration testing means but
there are analogies for infrastructures
code as well the pull request give us a
manual judgment and of course given that
we have the last version of the config
in our repository because we're just
changing it in a version store we also
have a nice vector to do things like
roll backs so basically it's the long
story short is that all the good design
principles about CIN CD that we apply
that we apply for applications we are
also able to apply for infrastructures
code here so get a little bit more
detailed one you know this all sounds I
think hopefully very nice and compelling
but now you actually have to make some
concrete decisions about okay I've got
this batch of infrastructures code I've
got multiple environments I'm going to
roll them out how do I reflect that in
my repository and again while cavi
adding it by saying that there was a
perfect answer for all situations what
we're going to present here is a
templated pattern or one particular
suggestion that you can use and you can
think about using in your setup and
again this is not the only way to do
things and I'm very happy to discuss
variations depending on your use cases
afterwards but we think this is a really
good place to start
so what we start with is we have a
master branch that will include in
different folders well we have yes we
start with a master branch that will
include in different folders the
configuration that we want to have in
each of the different environments that
we're rolling out to now this means that
this is what we want to have this
doesn't necessarily reflect what is
actually running in each of those
environments but it tells us what the
kind of like this is what we want to
move towards and especially as we make
changes to it so we might open a pull
request against this branch for instance
to change the prod the information in
the prod folder
that means that we are thinking about
making a change to the prod config it
doesn't mean that the prod config has
changed yet one of the things that we've
learned around kubernetes this is very
popular but in fact this can be done
with any kind of system is the idea that
we've get ups or with environments as
code as I like to call it it's very
useful not just to have what we're
talking about here which is that you
have folders that represent the desired
State but that you actually reflect also
in version control what the actual state
of your environment is so as we start
doing the deployment as we start
applying this config across our various
resources in GCP we want to have that
actual state reflected in our repo as
well because that gives us a history not
just of what we want it to happen but of
what actually happened so what you will
see is that the state of Master is
intended to reflect the state of the dev
environment right so what is in master
when something is in master we think
that that is what the dev environment
should look like and so the automation
is set up you will see that in the demo
that as we merge changes into master the
job is or the intent is that that should
mean make the dev environment look like
this the next stage in the progression
is once we're happy with the dev
environment and we want to move forward
we will take the staging environment the
information that's in the staging branch
and we will apply that to the staging
environment when it's merged to a
particular branch called staging and
then when we are happy with the outcome
of that we think everything is ok
staging actually looks ok the apps are
still running we want to go forward and
affect our production environment we
will take the changes and we will apply
them also to the prod branch and that
will show us what is actually in prod so
if you look at the broad branch in your
repo that will tell you what actually
happened or what the state of the
production environment really is right
now that's that I it's somewhat abstract
and it will become I think much more
real when you see the demo in a second
and so for that let me hand over to the
magic that Morgana is about to
thanks Andrew
so sorry skipped ahead there so for my
first demo I wanna focus on is actually
the shared foundations that's something
we were talking about it's not
necessarily project specific this is
things like networking billing I am
security controls all the stuff that is
shared across the organization often you
have a central team that's running this
sort of thing and really is very
important because it affects so many
different parts of the organization and
so many different applications
can depend on a sit on a shared we PC
for example so we're gonna show how you
can actually do that through
infrastructures code and have the same
pattern of rolling it out across
multiple environments specifically using
terraform which is a open source tool
developed by a partner hasshu Corp it
has support for multiple clouds but
great support for Google and in fact we
actually have a full-time team of Google
engineers who work to make sure there's
good support for terraform on GCP all
the same patterns that we're talking
about here can be used with more or less
any infrastructures code tool you can
use them with Google cloud deployment
manager the kings of terraform you can
use it with ansible you can use it with
whatever tool you are using to today why
can we looking at terraform and one of
the big things that actually has
different plugins of different providers
so that google provider is maintained on
primarily by google engineers so just to
go ahead to the demo there we go
cool so here I have my deployment repo
so this is just a simple repo it's for
my little sample organization that I
have and one of the big things that we
have as a principle is that you actually
want to separate it out so that you
don't have all of your code in a single
folder for all of your environments or
even for a single environment all the
different purposes you want to separate
that out by different purposes
particularly by different teams that
might be maintaining it so often pattern
we'll see is that there's a networking
team for example this maintaining
networking config comprised of both
automation engineers as well as any
traditional network engineers then I'd
be involved in looking at that as well
so within this networking folder I have
like Andrews talking about I have my
different environments in this demo I'm
just doing a very simple dev and prod so
we can have simplicity there where we
have each of the Terra firme files one
of the things you notice here is we
actually also have some files on the
route this is for files that are shared
across multiple environments so I don't
have to copy and paste the exact same
file
into each environment I can actually
have a shared file and just symlink it
into each directory where it needs to be
used and terraform automatically can
pick those up do deployment edge I can
as well so you can very easily share
code across these environments if you
need to if you want to have the same
file without copy and pasting so let's
jump into a dev environment here so you
hear a couple things there matter in
this file in this folder
each my environment I want to make sure
I have a back-end config this is used
for storing the terraform State so I'm
making sure that every every change I
made is actually still stored on Google
Cloud storage so I can roll back if I
need to I have version history there if
I want to collaborate across multiple
different CI runs it actually has
locking in place so it's gonna make sure
that two different CI runs aren't
attempting to manipulate State at the
same time as well as the ability to
revert back if necessary and then I've
got the provider config I've got a
couple variables for you know things
like what more my org ID is if I want to
be able to have that be easily
substitutable substitutable and then in
my main TF is where I start actually
configuring what my dev networking
environment looks like as you notice
most of the actual code that goes into
these individual environment folders can
actually module or template references
because in many cases you want to share
code across different environments so
you don't want to actually have all of
the config and all the complexity be
enough in the individual environment
specific holders you just want to have
the configuration that specific to that
environment so here's that I'm using
this VPC module which is one of our open
source modules that we have for working
with terraform on Google Cloud which is
used for setting up a shared previously
network so I specify I want my project
ideas I specify which subnets I want so
I want two subnets in here I specify any
secondary ranges I want for those
subnets as well and then you know this
is just using this is all of course
registered to the dev environment so I'm
not gonna use the same IP space for
example between both Devon pragma in
most cases right so I this is
configuration it matters just the dev
environment but I'm sharing a group I'm
able to use the same module in both
environments other parts the
configuration might be even more shared
where it's the case where you have the
exact same firewall rules in both
environments so this is where this
shared firewall rules module comes in
I'm able to reference this module and
just pass in the dev dev specific
information like the network the network
name and the host project that applies
to my dev environment into the shared
module so I'm not having to write the
same firewall can
for each environment I'm doing so that
goes that that's just a relative
reference to the same repo so it goes up
to this other modules directory where I
actually kind of shared bits of code I
want to share across there for
environments it's very easy to build a
module or template in both terraform and
deploy manager you just create a file
create a folder you have a module
instantly if there's no registration
process there's nothing special yet to
do any folder with a terraform file and
it automatically becomes a module so
this is why module four just for shared
firewall rules here very simple this
reference just has a couple inputs of
which project I'm hosting my network in
and the network that's on that prod that
the name for that network I'm what which
I also use in the firewall name and of
course I have my rules right now I only
have a single fire rule which allows
HTTP but let's go ahead and modify that
and add an additional rule let's say we
realize you know we actually have to at
least serve a redirect on HTTP because
people are going to our website and
realizing and getting frustrated they
couldn't access it so we're gonna just
add an allow HTTP rule let's could put
it there and let's just use the same we
can use the same target tag so this
config looks good and I'm gonna be
really dangerous here and actually just
commit it directly into the into the
master branch obviously not what you'd
want to do in the real environment but
you can see we can start to see and
we'll talk more about how you can
actually build a overall pipeline for
that but we'll just say add new firewall
rule right
and as soon as this is pushed into the
master branch cloudbuilt picks it up and
is going to start to build that right so
here you see push the master branch
deploy networking to the dev environment
so we have a cloud build pipeline that
automatically captures that runs
terraforming it in the direct in there
to make sure that all the modules are
downloaded make sure everything's in
place to be able to run everything you
can see it pulling all the doctor
containers here to run everything there
and that actually goes and applies it to
my environment so here we see we
download the Google provider I've the
latest version because I didn't have it
pinned and then the null provider and
then we can actually see what's being
created so we can see the allow HTTP
firewall rule is being created in my dev
environment on that project as I as I
expected and we notice we actually have
some of the variables get interpreted so
dev VPC allow HTTP so we had that as
expected and everything is complete all
set so if I go over here go to my
firewall rules I can see I now have the
Devi BBC allow HTTP and allow HTTP but
this isn't on prod yet right because we
only did it on Devon we want to make
sure everything's working great we want
to make sure you know we get a chance to
test that maybe we do some security
testing make sure that we're not somehow
exposing our application vulnerabilities
there that way but we it's only on dev
now let's say everything looks good the
Federal Rules great we want to promote
this same change to production that's
just a process of doing a pull request
from the master branch to the production
branch so I'm going to go ahead and go
into my route and create a new pull
request
so the base I'm still gonna do on my
rappel and I want to be actually my
production branch right only change here
was that new firewall rule otherwise
they're up to date so we can say yeah
let's I'm gonna do this as a release
candidate basically right so I'm going
to say this is what I want to move from
the dev branch into production there's a
chant there's a pull request here so
there's a chance for anyone who wants to
get feedback on it they can they can
come in and provide any details they
want everything there maybe I have to
have a certain number of reviewers
happen on our any production push you
could say that they have to come into
the pull request and put the looks good
to me for them but you can actually have
all your reviews and all of your
processes in place just through the pull
request as that sort of we our ability
to have manual judgments in place as
well as when you see how you want to run
it says there's no conflict so I can go
ahead and merge so I'm just going to
marriage it and that'll kick off an
additional cloud build yeah so we pushed
the production branch so now we can
deploy to networking to production it's
gonna run along do the same thing just
there and in a minute it'll show up here
with my new firewall roll back one of
the other things you can do actually is
also with the folder structure that we
talked I was talking about you can
actually have different owners for
different folders so you can make you
can do thing with most see most get
system support some form of ownership
but you can basically have a owners file
in each of these directories and similar
to what we do at Google or you can say
you know the networking we want all we
want a network team member to give a
approval on any change that touches this
part of the code so you can put that in
the owners file in the networking folder
you could have a different part for say
security changes that you want to have a
team there so you can have Auto
configure building over who has to
approve different pull request types
based on what the what infrastucture is
being affected cool alright that's
that's finished and there we go we have
the same change applied to prod we had
confidence then we had the exact same
commit being pushed into both branches
so we have full conference that we're
having the same train just being
promoted across the blood across the
lifecycle cool can go back to the slides
well so I mentioned modules they're a
primary method of code reuse in
terraform I should have showed a
definition of this one of the really
nice things is you can load modules from
many different sources so you can do it
from a local repository like I showed
there you can pull from the Terra from
module registry which is lots of The
Painted best practice modules out there
for you so you'll have to go out and
write your own module every time you
wanted to a network or do a firewall
rule for example you can also pull
modules straight from github tubes or
actually any gate instance so if you
have an internal gitlab repo you can
easily pull from there you can easily
share modules tonight they're the best
way to actually do code reuse in
terraform in fact we've done something
called the cloud formation toolkit which
is set a set of example and sample
modules for terraform that represent our
best practices and experience with
enterprise customers so these are these
cover things like creating you're
creating your Corby pcs creating
projects in a repeatable way managing I
am permissions creating gke clusters
they're secure and deployable
effectively and we have these templates
for both terraform and deploy manager
but you can download totally open source
all in github and we actually for next
actually made a nice website for it so
you can go there and I'll have the links
to everything and shows you how to use
it in some tutorials there I mean the
benefit of this is you actually instead
of you have to discover all the best
practices yourself and every team that
comes onto GCP having to figure out how
to create a project they you can just
take the modules it has all the best
practices baked into them and you can
focus on the parts that are specific to
your application use case and what's
needed particularly for your what's
different about your environment so
doing all the baseline stuff yourself we
also have some sample cloud build
pipelines we'll integrate that into
there as well
and the other thing we're trying to do
is actually have secure defaults for all
these modules because of the way that
GCB is built we actually want that
really easy getting started experience
that Andrew showed that you can you know
go on start your free trial start
playing with some services do a POC very
easily and that's really powerful
because we have that power of the cloud
to experiment and play freely but once
you start going to the state where
you're in an enterprise use case you're
doing hundreds of applications you're
moving entire workloads over you want a
little bit more consistency and
repeatable repeatability and you want
more secure defaults so that's what we
baked into these modules so these are
things like making sure that you
actually don't have internet egress on
by default on every any project you
create making sure that you have
of gke clusters by default have private
IPS has posed a public IPS so it's a lot
of enterprise defaults that we bake into
these modules as well I'm stoked on sort
of the enterprise use case for it's the
hobbyist or PSE use case cool so I
thought I said that I was recently
really dangerous earlier and in fact I
was when I committed directly to
production right I was I was I able to
push that change directly to development
they were still pull requests where I
was going from duality production but
ideally no changes are made to
infrastructure and all without some CI
feedback when we talk about the earlier
pipeline we would talk about having CMC
I so feedback that allows you to use
some sort of testing and sanity testing
on your code before it actually goes
into production so that's where having
PCI and cloud bill comes in and the
ability to make sure that human error is
accounted for we found its most the most
common cases of security in security on
in the cloud it is usually because
there's some humans configuration it's a
mistake are some just simple
misunderstanding of how the or even type
of how the configure sit up it's often
easier to easy to have miss
configurations especially when
everything's in code done the good
machine is exactly translating what you
have in the code so you wanna make sure
that your code is right before you
actually apply it that's where it's easy
and then we also want to we also realize
that actually can slow down cloud
adoption especially for enterprise
customers where you feel worried that
developers could easily make a mistake
and do what I did and just go commit
directly into master and have that
deploying to deploy into GCP environment
that can make security mistress a little
bit worried you know you want to make
sure that you have the right guard rails
in place you want to make sure that you
have everything you need which is why we
are introducing the idea of the
terraformed Balladur which can actually
look at your tear from config run policy
checks against it and determine whether
that tear from config violates any of
these policies before any changes are
made so this allows you to have
confidence in changes before they're
deployed to production before any of
your GCP researchers are updated we can
actually look at that config and give
you full conference that things like no
external IPS are being exposed that your
firewall rules are not too broad they
whatever policies matter to your
organization you can have them embedded
into your repo embedded into your CI
pipeline you can have the full
flexibility there it's where we released
this very recently this V zero point one
of you know I would say alpha
saw
for at this point but it's very early
but the idea is also we're trying to
build a community it's all open source
so everyone can collaborate on it it's a
CI about CI by NAR you can download you
can work with it and the the actual
policy library is also open source so
we've started with a couple handful of
constraints that we think are best
practices things like not having
external piece but we want to have more
of them over time and we encourage every
to be able to contribute to that and
actually have a full community driven
ecosystem of policies that ever can
contribute share and to have policy
policy configuration is code the same
way that were talking we're talking on
tariffs or modules for your actual code
you can have that same reusability there
across the board at the term from
browser how this actually works in
practice is as an administrator you go
to the Tara from valor repo you say okay
here's this here's the set of available
policies available constraints I'm gonna
pick these three constraints that matter
to me no external IPS no sharing I am
resources outside of the my domain and
every project that gets created must we
have a must have a label that's the
costs in there for it these can are
totally flexible administrators can
define which ones matter to them but you
can take it put it into your own repo so
you take the public repo fork it pull it
into your private repo and put enable
the policies that matter to you and then
the administrator says he's our policy
Weibo developers any time you're going
going to deploying to GCP it has to pass
this repo if it doesn't you're not
getting into GCP there's a developer I
can have the flexibility to actually
start working on code locally and know
if it's gonna break policy before I
actually even submit it to everyone so I
kind of a very fast feedback cycle where
I know I'm breaking policies before I
even submit the code right so I as a
developer locally write some terraform
code I can run the turf from browser
locally get immediate feedback there and
then once I submit it up into a git repo
as a pull request I also get feedback
there so I can make sure it's enforced
assuming the CI check looks good that I
can actually finally merge into
production or emerge into development
branches and have the full visibility
they're cool the other part of this is
actually that you take those same checks
the checks that we're talking about
where you have the pre deployment checks
as part of the tariff form and those
same policy library can be used with for
study which is our open source security
monitoring product which allows you to
do ongoing monitoring so in case some
developers somehow got console access or
there's some other there's some legacy
infrastructure that was in place before
you hide the terror from
in place we have for study just ongoing
monitoring against the same set of
policies and just detection if there's
any violations there and we'll send you
alerts put them into the cloud security
system in command center or send you a
any email alerts that you need any slack
notification make sure that if there's a
violation you know about it and you can
actually remediate it if you're
necessary I mean you can go in and find
out but so you have both sides the same
policy library use in both places so you
both doing pre deployment checks and
ongoing monitoring to make sure policies
are in place before infrastructure is
created and as infrastructure matures
and changes over time know how the
policies actually look like in practice
very there everything is very
declarative in nature very similar to
kubernetes style api's so this is if
anyone's to work with kubernetes this
looks very similar to a kubernetes
manifest so you hate having here this is
for iin policy members so you can say
what what constraint I'm using so this
is the I am allowed policy domain
remember domain constraint so just as
best specifying where can where a member
to my organization loud to come from so
what domains are let they allowed to use
right you can specify what configs you
want in there you can also do targeting
so you can say that you if there's a
policy that you want that only applies
to part of the organization you can
actually limit that down so this policy
we have it targeting the entire
organization or actually in fact all
organizations but that could just as
easily be targeting a specific folder or
a specific project within the
organization so you have that
flexibility to scope things down if
there's particular research that are
more secure certain environments that
have more sensitive data in them you can
have more restrictive policies on those
which is a sandbox environment where you
have might have less restrictive
policies similarly you can have the
exclusions by default there's nothing
excluded but you could if you had for
example a piece of legacy infrastructure
that needs to run with an external IP
for some reason you could actually scope
that down and put an exclusion in there
for just that project where that
instructure is running so you could
actually have white listing on this
policies as well so really flexible all
in all as code so it's really nicely if
you just check this in go repo your
policies you work on them to say well
you're working on your config as well
you can also do custom logic so this is
an example if you want to do this is the
Reg okoda regulus and opens open-source
policy language that you can actually
take that regular language and you can
write your own policies in it so you can
say I want to have a custom constraint
that student something like checking
that my
labels actually match my format match
the format for my naming convention
right so you may have an internal naming
convention that specifies that every
project has to match a certain standard
has have costed and embedded in it you
could just write some code that enforces
that constraint embedded into the policy
library and then all of your terraform
code that it's getting submitted and all
of your ongoing monitoring with for
study would automatically pick up that
constraint so you have full flexibility
to define your own policies you're not
constrained by what Google has available
this is just an example of some of that
logic so now let's really look at what
that looks like in practice
so I we showed this foundational
infrastructure before now I'm gonna put
on my developer hat and start to deploy
a VM so this development this app that
I'm working on he's only the dev
environment so far I haven't promote it
to production but I just have us an
empty main TF file for it so I'm gonna
go in and edit this file I've got my
handy dandy VM here so there's a couple
things I'm hearing I'm just gonna create
a single simple compute instance for my
back-end service that you'll be
deploying the GCP specifying the region
yeah the project I'm on it
one of the really cool things I can do
with having my ter from state stored in
Google Cloud storage is I kind of do
references across deployment so that
even though I'm not editing the
networking state I do actually have to
reference it because I have to know what
subnet to put my VM on so I can actually
very easily do that by referencing this
terraform remote state which goes and
pulls from the GCS bucket gets the
latest networking configure that's been
deployed into dev and actually grabs
what the app what the Apps subnet ID is
so wherever whatever export the
networking team is to identified as this
is the subnet we want you to put your
applications on there all that to do is
export that and I can just pull import
that very easily my traffic config
without ever having any manual
configuration there so this means the
next time they for some reason have to
change the subnet they can easily update
that and my config automatically grabs
the latest one I don't have to worry
about making any changes myself so this
looks cool I'm gonna do that but this
time I'm not going to commit directly to
master I'm gonna be you know good this
good safe developer and start a feature
branch
so so we're gonna create a feature
branch let's put in a nice pull request
name and this immediately kicks off a
cloud build now unlike our previous
cloud builds this one is actually just
doing testing it's not deploying
anything right so the first thing it
does it just runs terraform in it as
before it actually does terraform plan
so i can go in here and look at a plan
of what's expected to be created so i
can see it's expecting that it's going
to create a google compute instance it's
gonna have these parameters you know
what IP forward it's gonna be on this
this network you can see which subnet so
the actual subnet gets filled in and
completed there so i earlier in my code
i just have as a variable but here i can
see oh this is the u.s. one is something
that subnet dev subnet zero one so i can
make sure that do a sanity check there
and make sure everything looks good to
me and then finally it actually passes
it into the terraform valid air right
and uh-oh found violations constraint
forbid external IP on resource you know
resource my front end instance no
external IP czar loud so I accidentally
put an external IP I mean since even
though my organization has a policy of
no external IPS now if this configure
had been merged earlier I would have
accidentally exposed my network to the
Internet and we could have easily had a
big issue where there's IIPs I might
might not had to write firewall rules I
might not write secured you software in
that VM and I would might be getting a
call from security thankfully this got
caught before anything was actually
deployed and I had the full full ability
to know about that in fact the check
failed right so github is not even allow
me to merge that pull request it except
off your administrator because the check
failed because my policy was violated
their right and I can go back to the
cloud but look when we details I'm not
but having this enforcement the policy
compliance at the build stage with the
CIO checks that we were talking about
earlier now let's go ahead and update
that again because we want to make sure
that we actually can deploy because we
want to have a little bit of flip we
want to make sure that we can take off
the external IP so if I go here go to
the main TF that I have on my branch
and we're just going to take off this
access config part because the access
configures actually what gives it an
external IP that can make those changes
I go back to my pull request it's gonna
rerun the CI on it because I updated my
main tied made out to UF again it's
gonna do a new terraform plan so I can
make sure that whatever whatever change
ID merges the latest terraform plan so I
have full visibility into that and yeah
just have to pull these down and you
notice how like the fact that access
config by itself automatically creates
an external IP isn't actually always
entirely intuitive so that's one of the
benefits of this is that even if
somebody does something like just copy
and pasting example from the internet
that looks like it looks correct looks
intuitive
we'll make sure you can detect those
violations and you can't detect miss
configurations before they're applied oh
so cool I see my Terra firme plan and no
violations found because I don't have an
external IP now if we go up here and
look at it we see oh cool there's no
external IP on this there's no access
config for this network interface and
there's no external IP associated with
that so I'm just gonna go ahead and
merge that because I can merge now
because there's no block nothing
blocking it only policies passed and
that itself will also kick off another
CI run to deploy my app to dev so I can
actually automatically have my instance
deployed doing everything just through
github and through CI workflows and in a
minute it'll actually deploy the
instance up to here
yep there we go my front instance is
being front-end instance it's being
created can go back to the slides
oh so that's the demos we have today
the key takeaways check out the cloud
furnishing toolkit to get the templates
for deployment manager in terraform so
you can get started really easily check
out the terraform validator make sure
that you have more reliable reliability
in your infrastructure as code pipelines
so you can detect policy violations
before they actually happen and make
sure you can have security by actually
doing cloud build pipeline so you don't
have to do any management yourself
nobody's logging to any consoles I never
actually touched it I never touched the
shell in this entire demo I was just
working on entirely on github so you can
do collaborate on your infrastructure
entirely through code you never touching
a shell I mean used to the cloud build
pipeline so we have example Brad these
links and I think we have a Dory open
for questions if you have any as well as
we have mics around here if you want to
walk up and ask questions too let's give
them a round of applause
[Music]